here we go oh playing down okay
so first rounds it's important to set
the tone
um starting with the London let me
reduce the volume a little bit here
London opening
this is one of the main positions black
has a lot of moves here E6 Bishop F5 G6
E6 is the main main line
[Music]
yeah the move I like to play is Bishop
B5
that actually a Magnus inspired move
he's won a handful of really nice games
in this line
the idea is actually just to trade and
then play Queen A4
so there's a few different moves for for
black
a 97 is probably one of the more common
approaches there's Asics Queen E7
I think Bishop E7 is one of the more
topical lines like very strong level
with idea that like black doesn't want
to allow takes but
yeah 97
um we're still following
pretty well-known Carlson game
it was actually the very first video of
my London course is exactly this
position
I show how Carlson
completely crushed uh Grandmaster
busiocic
and it's a bit counter-intuitive to play
E4 like opening the center when my
King's in the center in box castled but
it's Justified because after he takes
takes there's a lot of targets that I
can exploit like the bishop takes takes
a rook is hit H7 could be hit
there's cases where I take on C5
and I'm also threatening E5 so not too
many options for black here
I still prep still following the Carlson
game
his game when takes takes Rook bead and
then takes
and again there's not too many options
for that because I'm hitting the bishop
foreign
still following the London course
rookie it is maybe the only I mean I
guess there's Knight D5 as well but
Knight Z5 I take probably
yeah and the problem for black the
bishop can't take because The Bishop's
pins of The Rook
and after it takes
um
Carlson took back but the Improvement is
actually Queen Dick's d8 allowing Bishop
takes F2 because after King takes Rook
takes
a punishes for signs wow
opening prep too strong
right I should explain what's like
what's about to happen here
engine will give I think plus 0.6 if I'm
not mistaken
but um actually let's see
real quick turning on the engine and the
position was not resignable
okay it's already plus one actually
I thought black was actually okay still
but um
yeah so the the Carlson game went takes
and then
uh F5 was played by both yogic and then
Carlson rattled off a really nice two
move sequence
starting with obvious Queen takes Queen
after Rook takes Queen this is white to
move and win
so if anyone chats wants to try and find
it or already knows it good job to
aesthetic
uh we don't move the bishop we play Pawn
C6
and uh yeah this move is just crashing
I think what happened in the Carlson
game like they played on for a bit
longer but the point is if takes there's
a fork a white swinging material
uh bossioches played this
and then after takes takes Rook D1 the
knight's basically coming to E5 and
it's really really nice
I had the game not too long ago that
followed basically the whole game
um
and now the Improvement on the Carlson
game is to actually take first
and
you can allow Bishop F2 because of the
same idea of Pawn C6
uh threatening C7 this is again winning
for light
and if Rook takes it's just a
transposition each seven is hit and and
black is currently down the pawn
so anyway it's probably one of my
quickest ever titled Tuesday wins
opponent just resigned
after 13 moves